welcome to the daily climate show coming
up
the war in ukraine must not be an excuse
to slow climate action world leaders
worn at davos
the cost of energy set to rocket by 40
in october the business secretary says
help is coming but unlikely to be in the
form of a windfall tax
and it's not just about carbon dioxide
we can't reach climate targets unless we
make drastic cuts in other emissions say
scientists
[Music]
hello and welcome to the daily climate
show where we track the changes
happening to our planet hear from the
leaders tasked with solving the problems
and explore the solutions now russia's
invasion of ukraine mustn't stop the
world from acting on climate change
that's the clear message coming from
world leaders meeting in switzerland
this week the u.s climate envoy john
kerry sounded a note of caution against
countries building new coal oil and gas
infrastructure in a bid for energy
security
what we can't do obviously
which some people are already pushing
for
is the notion that it needs a massive
build out of a whole
re-committal of the kind of
infrastructure we've had in the last
century
in order to meet this crisis we can meet
this crisis and meet the crisis of
ukraine
and the energy crisis of europe and
still deal
as we must with the climate crisis
and the eu commission chief said that
the challenge posed by russia's action
should lead to a faster transition to
clean energy
has only strengthened europe's resolve
to get rid of russian fossil fuel
dependency
rapidly
the climate cannot wait
but now
the geopolitical reasons are evident too
we have to diversify away from fossil
fuels
we have set our course already towards
climate neutrality
so now we must accelerate our clean
energy transition
our business correspondent paul kelso is
in davos
six months ago after the conclusion of
cop 26 in glasgow you might have
expected the big international meeting
like davos where politicians and private
sector power come together would be
dominated by the climate agenda and
while it's featured in many of the
panels here in davos the war in ukraine
has undoubtedly
stolen some of the oxygen and certainly
the short-term attention of political
leaders but particularly the european
ones who are here but what we heard
there from john kerry and from ursula
london line is that they could hope to
perhaps achieve a virtuous circle from
the necessity of cutting reliance on
russian oil and gas as a means of
cutting off vladimir putin's means of
funding his war in ukraine that could
hasten perhaps european and other
countries towards ending their reliance
on those fossil fuels and investing in
renewables so trying to harness the
short-term crisis just a few thousand
kilometers to the east of here towards
the longer term goals on the horizon of
cutting greenhouse gases is clearly what
particularly john kerry was trying to
get across perhaps the most significant
climate signal of all however is the
fact and the man that john kerry was
sitting next to on the stage his chinese
counterpart sharing a platform
expressing chinese government's view
that it is fully committed to reducing
greenhouse gases in the long term there
has been very little dialogue between
the us and china at any level that's
this little signal of a rapprochement
can some closeness and alliance over
climate maybe perhaps the most that
climate lobby can take away from davos
this year
now the energy price cap is expected to
rise in october to around 2
800 pounds that's according to the uk's
energy regulator jonathan breely told
the business energy and industrial
strategy committee that the amount
people will need to pay for gas and
electricity will rise by about 40
percent
the cap is currently 1
971 pounds the business secretary quasi
quatern told the same committee that
he's not keen on the proposal of a
windfall tax on oil and gas producers as
a solution
i've been very clear about the windfall
tax i don't think uh it supports
investment i don't think uh it's
necessarily the right thing but as i
always say uh that's up to the chance
that he sees
the the economy across the piece
he is responsible for fiscal policy
and
he's instinctively against windfall
taxes but if he feels that these
extraordinary times require
extraordinary measures
that's up to him
well joining me now our reporter
madeline ratcliffe so it looks like a
windfall tax on energy companies isn't
going to be imminent so are there any
short-term solutions to bringing
people's energy bills down
yes actually i mean as you saw from that
grab there isn't a huge amount of
consensus coming from government at the
moment about how to deal with this
crisis i mean which is not looming it is
here for so many people and the current
um financial incentives and rebates
aren't helping what what hasn't been
discussed yet is insulation of course we
had so much about during the interlake
britain protests it's not just activists
that have called for it labour's shadow
um climate secretary ed miliband has
asked the government to look at um
insulation friends of the earth suggest
that better insulation could save 40 off
energy bills for 8 million households
this could be
most energy experts that agree a really
long-term sustainable way of saving
money for households and of course
meeting our climate goals because if
less energy is wasted escapes from the
house we need less um gas or electricity
to heat it and as a country we will we
will use less and just this afternoon
the energy and climate intelligence unit
double down on those calls for more
insulation as a means to meet this
problem so i'd expect him more calls for
insulation in the coming days
interesting stuff madeleine thanks very
much indeed
let's get more then of the day's climate
news now and the heat wave that's baked
parts of india and pakistan over the
past three months is likely to happen
more frequently in future according to
an international group of scientists
the world weather attribution group
found that the heat wave was made far
more likely due to climate change and
with current levels of global warming
deadly heat waves are 30 times more
likely to hit south asia
the dutch airline klm is being hauled up
in court over accusations that its
advertising is misleading and amounts to
greenwashing in what's believed to be a
world first case against the aviation
industry
environmental lawyers client earth will
argue that the airline's adverts and
carbon offsetting scheme give a false
illusion of the sustainability of its
flights and plans to tackle its
pollution
they claim this violates european
consumer law klm has so far not
commented
protesters have interrupted shell's
annual shareholder meeting which was
being held in the uk for the first time
activists from extinction rebellion and
other groups glued themselves to chairs
and interrupted proceedings reading out
speeches accusing shell of human rights
abuses it comes as the chief executive
of offshore energies uk deidre michie
told an energy conference that
environmental activists could undermine
the uk's energy security
and put net zero ambitions at risk this
she said is because a disruptive protest
damages investor confidence in the uk
and would potentially lead to dependence
on other countries for energy supplies
now carbon dioxide is the greenhouse gas
most responsible for warming the planet
most of it coming from burning fossil
fuels but the focus on cutting just
carbon dioxide is not enough to stop
global warming now new research points
out that a sharper focus on other
emissions such as methane would help to
reduce heating in the short term and
keep that 1.5 degree limit within reach
and if we look at our data dashboard now
the global warming index currently
estimates that we're above 1.2 degrees
already
now the other important chart is this
one so this we can see here is the
concentration of methane in the
atmosphere rising very fast as you can
see there methane is in the short term a
much more powerful pollutant the carbon
dioxide but it also leaves the
atmosphere much faster so any reduction
in emissions would have a much faster
positive effect well let's talk about
this a little bit more now because
joining me now is jonathan banks he's
the global director of the methane
program with the clean air task force so
welcome to you and what difference would
it make to climate change if we cut
methane emissions as well as carbon
dioxide
well the difference is quite dramatic
if we cut methane emissions
today
by roughly 45 percent
we can knock off 0.3 degrees celsius
from the warming that we're currently
feeling when you say 0.3 it doesn't
sound like much but
when you talk about climate change and
the 1.2 degrees that you're showing on
the previous chart 0.3 is a huge deal
methane is the only thing that we have
are the only tool that we have to start
slowing both the rate of warming as well
as total warming
in the near term if we do these kinds of
reductions we can see a dramatic impact
in the next 20 or 30 years which is huge
well yeah and encouraging if it can be
achieved so how do you go about it how
do you cut methane
well i think that's the other very
hopeful thing about
working on this issue is
these are things that don't require you
know
technologies that don't exist today
these are things that require best
practices
and good technologies that people are
already using in the oil and gas space
it's about good practices fixing leaks
replacing equipment that's designed to
leak gas
i always talk about this as it's not
rocket science it's plumbing and that's
basically what it is we have everything
we need right now to be able to address
these emissions and get the benefit of
the climate and um uh immediately so
we've got the tools there is there the
political will as well we did see that
deal didn't we i think it was that the
us and the eu launched this pledge to
cut methane emissions by 30 by 2030
before cop last year so does that mean
we're on track
it means we have the political will and
now we need the implementation of that
um
the global methane pledge
brings together over 110 countries
pledging to reduce their methane
emissions
but a pledge is not action and i think
that's the critical piece between now
and the next copt in in egypt we need to
see countries stepping forward to take
action to make good on the commitments
that they've made to the global meeting
pledge okay jonathan banks very
interesting to get your take on it
thanks very much indeed
thank you and that's it from me today
thanks for watching i'll hand you back
to sarah jane